police are on the scene of a deadly
crash near fort apache and warm springs
streets in that area are closed at the
moment let's get right out to madison
kimbrough who is live at the scene with
more madison
yeah currently arby avenue is closed off
in the canyon trails area you know it's
a very active scene as a lot of
neighbors are still looking around this
crash happened around 3 p.m this
afternoon the person driving the car is
suspected of driving while drunk
according to police there were four
people in the car total three survived
with minor injuries edgar almante who
lives in the neighborhood shares what he
saw as he was driving
in the back of my rear mirror and i saw
a car spin out of control it was just
spinning left and right left and right
it hit the wall from side to side i
decided to turn around and i actually
called 9-1-1 and i was the one you know
kind of like making sure that everybody
was okay in the car
but then we noticed there was somebody
that got ejected out of the vehicle
according to elmonte they were driving a
tesla and the driver of the vehicle was
taken in by police suspected of a dui
edgar says it didn't look like any of
them were wearing their seat belts now
keep it here on 8 news now as we will
bring you the latest details coming up
at 6 p.m reporting live in the southwest
valley madison kimbrough live local now